thankfully critical parts of the machine
are falling apart which gives me hope i
mean cnn is basically a democrat super
pac that no one watches
facebook is cratering which is really
really interesting to see rumble which
you and i really care about is ascending
so there are certain trends right now
that kind of go into maybe the machine
isn't as strong as it once was
americans trust in government as an
all-time low americans trust in
corporations are at all time low you're
starting to see people care more about
local than national trends which is
really really important so i think i
think the machine is way weaker than it
was even a year ago
dave rubin and joining me today is the
host of the charlie kirk show the
founder of turning point usa and the
author of the maga doctrine the only
ideas that will win the future
charlie old friend welcome back to the
reuben report
dave you're a good friend honored to be
here thank you for having me we've done
this a couple times and i thought how
can i approach this interview in a way
that's a little different than uh what
we've done before so i thought we'd
start off give me your top 10 reasons
you love joe biden
top 10 reasons i love joe biden that's
um
you know i will say he's actually made
me prioritize things in life that matter
not to say politics don't matter yeah
but it's been such a dumpster fire you
have to kind of look outside of all the
madness
and you're like okay what really matters
in life right like what exactly gives
you purpose and meaning because
obviously
the things that you know we used to i
used to look at the presidency as
something i revere and i guess i still
do and i love my country but he's been
so awful it's like okay there's a couple
things i can control in my life like
family and relationships friendships uh
career and i'm gonna focus on those
things and it's kind of the one of the
few things i want to thank joe biden for
is he has reinforced at least for me
things that i control and things i
cannot control unfortunately i can't
control the southern border i can talk
about it it's wide open and it's a total
disaster but uh besides that i'm not i'm
not sure uh sure what else i would put
on that list dave
i thought maybe you could come up with
three i thought maybe there were going
to be three but i'll i'll accept that
but for a guy like you yeah go ahead
well i mean i guess if you want to kind
of do the whole like
you know glass half full thing and the
perpetual optimus thing and the best
thing about being surrounded is you can
shoot in any direction thing
which is
basically look i do think that
there's been unintended consequences of
what this regime has been trying to
implement which is the rise of the
citizen and
try who you were gonna get there that
was one of the three i had in there
right and like the the homeschooling
revolution and people really caring
about their country again and there is a
window there's an opportunity there's a
chance there's a sliver i i don't think
it's by any chance certain that this
backfires on them so dramatically that
it could be a political realignment the
likes of which our generation
we haven't seen in 30 or 40 years
do you believe in the machine enough to
believe that something like that could
happen because that's the direction i
thought you were going to go because
it's like everything is so bad
everything is so upside down even for
guys like us who expected this thing to
be bad it's worse than most of us could
have imagined but do you think the
machine will allow like just in the last
couple days watching the narrative on
kovid shift like
do you think it'll allow what should
happen to happen that the voice of the
people will actually be heard
well thankfully between the media and
the whole thing that's what i'm talking
yeah well no for sure of course yeah
thankfully critical parts of the machine
are falling apart which gives me hope i
mean cnn is basically a democrat super
pac that no one watches
facebook is cratering which is really
really interesting to see rumble who
which you and i really care about is
ascending so there are certain trends
right now that kind of go into maybe the
machine isn't as strong as it once was
americans trust in government as an
all-time low americans trust in
corporations are at all time low you're
starting to see people care more about
local than national trends which is
really really important so i think that
i think the machine is way weaker than
it was even a year ago and let alone
five years ago i think that there is
kind of like a natural law component to
this where if you try to build a
multi-trillion dollar
i should say it prob the laws of gravity
are probably going to push back against
you at some point there will be leaks in
dissension civil war fracturing and
you're seeing a lot of that not just
within the democrat party but within a
lot of the superstructures that you and
i believe the actual power
is vested in so look i could have a
cynical take where i'm like you know
what these people always have power the
infrastructure is impenetrable but i'm
not so sure of that i think i think that
there is a revival to challenge all
these institutions and dave you've
played a really important part in this
which is those of us that love freedom
and love the constitution as the
greatest political document ever we're
building our own infrastructure we're
building our own machine
and that's been a really exciting trend
i think the regime is really surprised
by it i think they're shocked quite
honestly that we've been able to kind of
stand up
a youtube competitor a payment
processing competitor a patreon
competitor like locals
so quickly you're starting to see a
higher education competitor of
university of austin and all of a sudden
this kind of
this
this
monopoly they had on these certain goods
and services and credentialing
institutions is being challenged in a
very serious way but they're still
they're still way more powerful than us
there's no doubt
but i'm optimistic that there might be
some legitimate fault lines that are
going to materialize in in their demise
that would be a slightly better great
reset than the great reset that they've
been telling us about but i'm curious
for you
look i i know you i know you off camera
too at this point but i don't know that
i've ever fully asked you this before
like you know you were so obviously a
close uh associate and and through
turning point in the trump's campaign
and you wrote the book the mega doctrine
the whole thing to go from that and you
know i would go to turning point the
night that i met trump at mar-a-lago we
were at dinner that very night there and
it was after an event you put together
and all that stuff and i say that
because you were so associated with that
now he's not empowered i just wonder for
you personally
like what did the last year show i'm not
talking about the political part of my
guy's not in power anymore but just like
the other you were part of something
that was fun and cool at least from our
perspective and now you ain't in it or
you know the thing exists but like it's
not in power anymore so like what is
that just personally for you like
well first it was really demoralizing
not from like an access standpoint or
like the fact you could call the
president like whatever it was just kind
of demoralizing for the country right i
mean especially the month of january
we're like okay
you know at new year's i remember
thinking all right okay biden's gonna be
president at the very least we can win
these senate races in georgia
you know we can have a check and balance
separation of powers
and then january 5th happened like okay
we lost that and then january 6 happened
which was a catastrophe right uh for a
variety of different reasons and so it
was a demoralizing couple weeks in 2021
and our team at turning point usa which
has always been educationally focused
and our team at the charlie kirk show
which has obviously been very aligned
with the trump doctrine and his
worldview
what do we stand for and we really went
to work you know i traveled 330 days uh
in the year of 2021 and went to campuses
and churches and
we didn't talk a lot about trump
honestly we didn't talk about biden
either more than anything else we talked
about what it meant to be an american
and what we stood for and why we stood
for it and it was definitely this moment
where
i also had to kind of reintroduce myself
to a lot of people that just kind of
knew me as oh you're the guy that
defends trump right and it was i think
very well received in a lot of different
ways and i also think it forced
our team and our show to go a level
deeper i spent more time in 2021 of
reading deep books and spending time in
very complex philosophy and really
challenging my ideas and why i believe
it and where does it come from because
it wasn't just kind of like okay the
left is out of their mind we have to
defend the president we have because
he's doing a really good job
and you can kind of get really used to
that right um but then all of a sudden
when he's displaced from power there's a
lot of people that are saying okay do we
want to go back to like the liz cheney
kind of way of doing things or why do we
want you know borders to be controlled
and so you have to kind of come come
from that with an approach that is
philosophically based and rooted in
natural rights doctrine and also in
timeless ideas while also respecting the
fruits of the enlightenment all these
really important things
and so i think that we've been i think
we're better because of it honestly i
think our show's more interesting i
think our organization is stronger i
think we're reaching more people um and
you know i'm not to say not to say that
i'm thankful i mean the country's in
horrible shape but i think we i think we
were able to use what was an adversarial
situation or a set of circumstances to
our advantage if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell